this this is big news or so I'm told I'm
assured I'm assured that this is big
news that Megan and Harry have put in
there two weeks notice and are quitting
the royal family or rather as they put
it there they intend to step back as
senior members of the royal family which
I didn't realize was an option you know
though now that I know that it is I've
been working on my wife to explore this
possibility with my in-laws
I mean Megan think that was Megan margul
actually convinced her spouse to resign
from her in-laws so in that way she's a
legend I think she's living the dream
she's a she's an example for us all if I
could just get my wife to show up to a
hour to her family's Thanksgiving next
year with a resignation letter that's
that's my goal but I guess I shouldn't
joke about this because this is very
serious very serious issue very serious
indeed because with with this
dismantling of the royal family the
royal family will be less equipped less
capable of performing their essential
duties such as wearing pretty clothing
and waving III I'm worried that they'll
be able to do less waving than they know
then they would normally do and I'm not
sure if the world can continue spinning
honestly without without them performing
that task but personally I you know I
can't I can't say as important as that
is I can't say that I blame Megan and
Harry that much because they want to
live their own lives and and and who
would want to be a useless figurehead
honestly well I guess I would actually I
would enjoy that so if the royal family
is looking for a fill in a replacement I
have my resume and I'll send it to the
Buckingham Palace I have a lot of
experience not doing stuff so I'm very
good at being useless so you know and I
put that on my resume I'll send it over
then again I guess I read about
two-thirds of one article about this
situation so maybe my analysis is
completely off I will say that you know
Megan I guess as I've been talking about
this online a lot of people Americans
and Brits have told me that I'm I'm way
off and Megan Markel is a villain is a
villainous woman who's she's a sleeper
agent sent by America to undermine the
royal family finishing the job that
George Washington started which to me
again would just make her a hero but
they say is she's a terrible person I
don't know you know I really don't know
the I don't know the dynamics of these
people I don't think anybody does but I
will say that you know Prince Andrew is
you want to talk about a villain
Prince Andrew was good friends with
Jeffrey Epstein allegedly raped one of
Epstein's child sex slaves at least one
allegedly and is being protected by the
royal family
so I guess excuse me if I'm not too
broken up about the fact that they're
suffering this misfortune
when they're protecting this alleged
child rapist everybody made a big joke
about it and I joked about it too
because of what a clown this guy is not
joking about what he did obviously but
when he when he gave that interview to
the BBC a few months ago or a few weeks
ago and his excuses his alibi was just
so laughably weak the only thing that
makes it not laughably is when you think
about what he actually allegedly did but
remember his excuse was number one he
said that he's he's he was friends with
Jeffrey Epstein because he's so
honorable he Prince Andrew is such an
honorable guy and he's even he's even
Tuan he's willing to admit that he's too
honorable he's a little bit too
honorable and so all of that great honor
had had for whatever reason convinced
him to be friends with this convicted
pedophile he never explains why that's
honorable I guess because everybody else
is ostracizing the pedophile and Prince
Andrew was gonna take him under his wing
and show him compassion because he's
such an honorable guy so that was his
first alibi his first excuse his second
excuse was that the the woman accusing
him said that he was very sweaty when
when she was being assaulted by him and
he said that no it couldn't have in him
because he knows that he wasn't sweating
back then he checked his calendar and
because he keeps a log of all the times
that he sweats and he checked his
calendar and no he didn't sweat on that
day he sweated on others days but not on
that particular day that was really his
excuse that he knows he wasn't sweating
then so it couldn't been him and so
everybody has a nice little laugh about
how silly that excuse is but what are we
talking about here we're talking about
this guy allegedly raped somebody child
and his excuse is so ridiculously
unbelievable
yeah he's not gonna be held to account
you think Queen Elizabeth was such such
honor and dignity
you think she's working behind the
scenes to make sure that he that he's
held accountable for what he allegedly
did you think she's doing that or is she
more concerned about the image of the
royal family what do you think that the
Honourable dignified wonderful Queen
Elizabeth is worried about so to me when
I talk about the royal family
that to me is the thing that I'm focused
on I I really you know to me I think
it's a big deal it's a big deal if a
member of the royal family allegedly
raped the child and was friends with
Jeffrey Epstein a global sex trafficker
convicted pedophile I think that's the
thing that we should worry about but it
seems like the attitude for a lot of a
lot of people not just Brits but
Americans as well yeah but you know
they're the royal family they're they're
basically above the law it's the royal
family we're talking about here I don't
get it
all right um well the so let's go let's
go talk about the Democrats a little bit
speaking of speaking of things I don't
get the Democrats especially recently
have been of course coming to the
defense of our nation's enemies and the
Democrats have been very open about
doing so have have not not been shy
about it at all we've gone over many
examples this week and and last week of
the Dems
openly defending Iran and engaging in
pro-iranian propaganda so here's the
latest this is representative Pramila
jayapal at a press conference yesterday
says this is after we found out that
Iran's reprisal consisted of a symbolic
missile launch that didn't hurt any
human being apparently and so here's
what Jaya Paul has to say watch this is
the result of reckless actions by
President Trump of military
brinksmanship president Trump recklessly
assassinated Qasem Soleimani
he had no evidence of an imminent threat
or attack and we say that coming from a
classified briefing where again there
was no raw evidence present
that there was an imminent threat
recklessly assassinated this again is
absolutely indistinguishable from the
language and the rhetoric that the
Iranian government is using she could
have been standing in Tehran making
those remarks and it wouldn't have
seemed out of place at all it would have
seemed exactly good that that's the kind
of thing that they're saying and not
that this matters of course to her or to
the other Dems but to call it a reckless
assassination is false on multiple
levels
first of all reckless okay you could get
away with with that characterization
last week but now it's been confirmed
that the move to take out Soleimani was
a brilliant strategic strategic play it
had cost us nothing in terms of American
lives
the reprisal from Iran was a face-saving
measure meant to give them cover in
front of their own people their own
citizens
I mean complaining that this was
reckless now that's like if a team goes
for it on 4th and 5 and makes the
conversion scores a touchdown and then
you as a fan are still mad at the coach
for making a risky coaching decision
maybe it was risky but it worked so why
aren't you happy as an American why
aren't you happy that this arguably
risky play worked out for America and
then assassination she calls an
assassination this once again it's just
false it is despicable pro-iranian
propaganda it is non assassination an
assassination is the illegal murder of a
public official or public person for
political reasons political or
ideological reasons this on the other
hand was a lawful strike against an
enemy in a war zone after that enemy had
coordinated two attacks against
Americans assassination that's
completely absurd was the killing of bin
Laden in assassination well no because
that was done under Obama so that's a
totally different situation
we are told speaking of speaking of
repulsive watch watch this and I'm very
glad to say that I was part of the
hundred and thirty-two and also the vote
for Barbara leaves amendment but I think
that the point of that is that that is
the same war that we're dealing with
today we never solved any
problems with AUMF we left 4,000 plus
made 4,400 dead and over 60,000 who came
back injured in some form and the war
never ended as I recall the language in
AUMF it deals with hostilities in Iraq
it doesn't deal with an incident or a
dislike or someone in a car coming in
from the airport that is the danger of
not acting and I do think without
leadership meaning the leadership of CPC
that will come together around specific
answers now if you're listening to the
audio podcast you couldn't see what was
happening there but as Sheila
jackson-lee
is talking about American casualties
she's talking about American soldiers
who were killed or injured Ilan Johann
Omar is in the background laughing and
giggling with the people around her
carrying on you know as American
casualties are being discussed this
woman I say repulsive a she really is
repulsive she is she is I think not it
not a good person there is no evidence
at all that she loves this country or
cares about it she's utterly devoid of
anything approaching class or grace
she's a liar she's consistently snide
and dismissive about the deaths of
Americans whether that whether it's this
we're talking about or when she was
discussing 9/11 and I know that when see
here's the thing when when conservatives
like myself complain about somebody like
Ilhan Omar having zero class and zero
grace the immediate response from the
other side is to say are you serious
what about Trump so they'll go to what
about Trump thing are you saying Trump
has class and grace well personally no I
don't think he does
I certainly when I think of all the
words to describe or to apply to Donald
Trump class and grace neither of those
come up but what's the difference you
know why is it that the
assless nests of Ilhan Omar tends to rub
people the wrong way more than the class
lessness of some web of Donald Trump or
you know why is it that he could get
away with some of that stuff but she
can't
what's the reason well because we've
never had any reason to suspect that
Donald Trump hates America or hates our
country you know we've never had any
reason to suspect that he's never said
anything that would make us believe that
now we know that Donald Trump hates a
lot of people he hates the media he
hates anybody's who's insulted him so
when he's being vicious and dismissive
which he can be of course it's always
directed at some particular individual
or a particular group like the media
who's attacking him and if you attack
him and assault him he's gonna insult
him he's gonna come after you that's the
way Donald Trump works and I think that
that doesn't upset people because number
one when it comes to the media a lot of
people hate the media and the hatred is
very well deserved
that's why CNN lost that lawsuit against
or lost the the lawsuit that was filed
against them by the Covington Catholic
kids but also people sort of understand
even if Donald Trump can go overboard
many of the times people understand the
idea of well if someone attacks you then
you attack them and so we get that but
he's never directed that at Americans as
a whole that's that's the problem with
the hannam art I think Democrats just
don't understand this they struggle to
understand this that we as Americans we
actually want you to love our country I
mean can you believe it that's what it
that's sort of the unforgivable sin for
and it makes sense that it's
unforgivable if you're an American
politician you could do a lot of bad
stuff you can say a lot of bad things
but that we need to see and believe that
you at least love our country if you
don't and if we don't see that that is
unforgivable of course it is given your
job is to represent the American people
you are working for America
so at a minimum we need to see that and
that's the problem that's why it upset
us so much when Donald when when barack
obama was going around the world
apologizing for america talking badly
about his own people in other countries
i know this is hard for democrats to
understand but you just you got to try
to get it through your head most
americans love their country and they
want their representatives and their
politicians to love it too that's all
and i see no evidence of that with the
Ilhan omar i see a lot of evidence to
the contrary with not just her but many
of the other democrats and their
performance with with this thing with
iran is just talk about unforgivable and
it is definitely evidence that you do
not love your country
you're taking sides with an enemy who
has just attacked us and you're taking
sides you're taking their side and
engaging in propaganda for them after
they've just killed an American they
have an attacked an embassy
and then we take out a global mass
killer and one of the most dangerous
terrorists in the world and you're
you're practically weeping over it yeah
we're gonna see that we're gonna think
well you must not love this country very
much and that to us is going to be way
worse than anything Donald Trump has
ever said
all right more to discuss but first a
word from Rock Auto you know with the
ever increasing number of cars and car
makes and models it's now impossible to
stock all the parts you need in a
traditional chain storefront you want to
go to a physical store is just it's a
it's a there's a limited space
so why endure often pointless or
seemingly intimidating questions and and
waits while the the guy behind the
counter orders the parts on his computer
choosing the only brand his warehouse
happens to carry you know there's no
point in doing that you have computers
yourself and so you can go and access
rockauto.com at your home and or you
could pull your your phone out of your
pocket and do it that way there's no
point in going to the store you're just
gonna order it online why not cut out
the middleman order it online yourself
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Park customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they got engine control
modules brake parts tail lamps motor oil
new carpet whatever you need they've got
its rockauto.com catalog is unique very
easy to navigate quickly you can see all
the parts available for your vehicle and
you could choose the brand you could
choose the specification you could
choose the prices you prefer you're not
relying on the guy behind the counter at
the auto parts store to do that for you
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
reliably low and they're the same for
everybody
amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car truck right Walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you okay here's a bit of
cringe for you today in cringe which
could be a segment on the show I thought
about making it a segment but a lot of
times I think about things that would be
good recurring segments on the show but
then I'm too lazy and I think well yeah
but then I got to do it all the time and
that takes out for it so anyway so today
in cringe here's a Lizabeth Warren
giving some advice to the youngsters you
see it here she says you deserve better
dump the guy who ghosted you convinced
the roommate to let you adopt a dog and
I'll take care of canceling your student
loan debt dump the guy who ghosted you
says elizabeth warren first of all
nobody above the age of 19 should be
using the phrase ghosted you really
nobody should be
because it's it's supremely stupid but
especially when you're in your sixties
but if you are gonna use it this is one
of the yes this is a this is a rule here
where if you're gonna try to relate to
the youth as an old person by using
these terms you have to use them
correctly so I'm pretty sure if you're
ghosted by someone that means that
they've dumped you right they've dumped
you they've ditched you and without
saying anything and they're gone
that's what ghost it is so how are you
gonna dump someone who's already dumped
you that's kind of a you can't fire me I
quit sort of move so that doesn't make a
lot of sense um and this is a very
important issue so I'm glad we could
talk about that on that note speaking of
important issues here's something
reading now from The Daily wire
Washington DC having solved all of its
other problems may delete and replace
gendered language from the DC city code
and the city's Home Rule Charter in its
next legislative session putting an end
to mail terms like manhole chairman and
fireman
Decius reports that quote currently our
older laws show outdated thinking about
gender with a default to masculine
pronouns or to masculinized forms of
nouns in if the 43 page bill passes
Washington DC residents will no longer
be subjected to the emotional distress
that accompanies seeing such gender
terms in everyday life at least as far
as Washington DC code and charter are
concerned so it's gonna rename chairman
to chairperson bondsmen will be bond
person fireman will be firefighter or
maybe fire person Ombudsman will be
Ombudsperson mmm let's see man
would be human made manpower would
become workforce man hole would become
people hole or no maintenance
maintenance cover okay that makes more
sense and you get the idea a couple of
quick points here first of all it's
obviously ridiculous to be offended by
any of the quote gendered language
listed above but manhole cover so the
lid to the hole that leads to the sewage
system has the word man in it and
feminists feel left out so when you see
a manhole cover someone talked about
manhole cover you feel left out as a
feminist you want to be included in that
okay look I'm I'm willing to give that
one up I've talked to the male
delegation and we've discussed it and
we've said you know what we that's fine
you can have that one in fact you can we
don't have to make a gender neutral it's
a feminist you can just make you you can
whatever you want you can make that
particular you could call it we can call
it a feminist hole if you want go ahead
if it makes you feel better and
feminists do tend to spew a lot of
sewage so it would sort of make sense
second thing quickly here it's
interesting to me and I've been waiting
for this and you see you you hear you
see gestures towards this every once in
a while you see wisdom you hear whispers
of it but but you don't often see people
explicitly going after the term woman
itself but of course the term woman has
man in it also so you can't even talk
about women without including men that's
the reality and it's worse than that
actually because if you follow the
etymology of the word now it's not true
that a lot of people think that woman
the etymology is womb man so you know
womb man a man with a womb which these
days those exist I'm told but that's not
actually the etymology the etymology is
it goes back to the Old English with men
which means wife so the word woman
really means wife which means that women
are being defined literally by their
relationship to men I think of the sec
of that my god so we need to get around
to changing that to let's not forget
that's my only point we got it we got to
think of another word for a woman
entirely if we want to be completely
gender neutral okay let's now check in
with our friends at Ashford University
flipping the calendar creates endless
possibilities new and exciting
opportunities are coming your way you
just have to be ready for them and it
all starts with earning your master's
degree at Ashford University you can
make this year make this year the year
that you really advance your career and
you advance toward your own goals by
earning your master's degree get started
today at Ashford University you know
these days you can't always get that
opportunity that job you wanted with a
bachelor's degree that's the reality of
the situation and you might find that
you need to get that master's and that's
where Ashford University comes in
Ashford University's online masters
degree program allows you to learn at
your own pace you can study wherever
you're the most comfortable learning
Ashford University's six-week long
courses allow you to take one course at
a time being enrolled in one class -
perd means you're considered a full time
students who are taking your time yet
your own pace your own leisure you're in
your own home or wherever you want to be
and you're taking these classes get
ready to grab new opportunities start
your master's degree today enroll now by
going to Ashford dot edu slash Walsh
that's Ashford dot edu slash walls to
start your master's degree today Ashford
dot edu slash Walsh okay before we read
some emails Jillian Michaels who is what
is she a fitness guru I think she was
being interviewed by BuzzFeed and
BuzzFeed interview is always always a
lot of great insightful content comes
out of those and she said she said some
things about Liz o that have caused
backlash wisdom personally found and I
love celebrities like Liz O or Ashley
Graham who are really preaching
self-acceptance I love her music yeah
well a percent I don't know anything
about her I'm sure she's a cool awesome
chick yeah and I love that they're
putting images out there that we
normally don't get to see of bodies that
we don't get to see being celebrated and
why are we celebrating her body why does
it matter that's what I'm saying like
why aren't we celebrating her music cuz
it isn't gonna be awesome if she gets
diabetes well I
I'm just being honest like I love her
music like my kid loves her music but
there's never a moment where I'm like
and I'm so glad that she's overweight
like why do we why do I even care why is
it my job to care about her weight you
know people are upset about this saying
how dare you comment on Liz OHS body how
presumptuous how judgmental of you well
if you if you recall Liz OH just as one
example she went to a basketball game
in pants where the butt region was cut
out so when you dress like that I think
what you want is for people to notice
and comment on your body so whatever
comments come you know when you dress
like that whatever comments come yet
that's that's that's on you you had that
coming because you that's obviously what
you are going out of your way to solicit
provoke comments about your body second
point this this is the kind of thing
that when people make comments like this
like Jillian Michaels did that hey let's
not talk about her body and you know
she's in it she doesn't say it but Liz
owes morbidly obese and that's not
healthy it's it's not good to be obese
it'll kill you get diabetes there's
nothing great about that and so that's
basically our point it's the kind of
thing that people on Twitter get upset
about but I think in the real world
everybody understands this I think most
people you talk to understand that yeah
we shouldn't be celebrating obesity of
course not that doesn't mean that we're
doesn't mean that we are bullying obese
people or that we hate them or anything
it's actually exactly the opposite
but you know there are there are certain
things we talked about loving your body
we talked about this a few weeks ago
this whole concept of loving your body I
don't even know what that means first of
all I mean what does that effectively
mean to love your body
I mean you are your body you have your
body whatever you however you want to
put it I don't know I don't know what it
means to love it or why you should be
focused on that you probably shouldn't
spend much time focused on your body one
way or another you shouldn't spend time
staring in a mirror trying to conjure up
the right kind of feelings about your
body who cares about how you feel about
your body just go live your life but to
whatever extent you can love your body
you shouldn't love the things that are
going to kill you the things that are
objectively unhealthy especially if you
can help them so if you've got some kind
of chronic condition or disease or
something well there's nothing you can
do about that but even then it would be
kind of weird to say you love it doesn't
mean that I'd say I love my chronic
condition of course you don't love it
but if it's something you can help then
you can change then you shouldn't love
it and you should try to change it
that's all it's just basic common sense
nothing to be upset about there let's go
to emails Matt wall show at gmail.com
Matt wall show at gmail.com is from Emma
says hi Matt I had a situation arise at
my work the other day would love to hear
your opinion on the subject an employee
of five years is leaving our business
the employee was a great asset very
well-liked amongst the office always
cared to do a good job the employee got
another job from a larger corporation
who can offer her more money better
benefits a higher chance of moving up
within the company the employee wasn't
looking for a different job at the time
but couldn't pass up the offer the
employee gave our boss a month's notice
because they didn't want to leave us
empty-handed and wanted to help train a
new employee taking over that position
the employee also had a week's worth of
vacation time that they decided to take
the last week before they left do you
think that they're in the wrong for
taking a week's vacation after putting
any four week notice thanks for all you
do love the show I don't even see the
controversy here Emma's our people at
your job upset about this I know I don't
I know
see any problem with it whatsoever
that's her time it's in her employment
contract she has every right to take it
I don't see any controversy here
personally I'm a firm believer in using
your vacation them you have vacation
time that's your time you over write to
it contractually why are you gonna do
your employer a favor
do a little a little charity and and so
I'll give you back the time why why
should you they're probably not gonna do
you any favors so use your time yeah no
problem with it at all
let's see this is from K says dear man I
really appreciate your show I have a
marital question how do you divvy up the
responsibilities / chores in your
household between you and your wife my
husband and I have been married for less
than three years but we're having a lot
of problems lately and have been having
too many arguments and fights because we
can't agree on who should be doing what
from my perspective I do probably 90% of
everything from cooking the cleaning to
all kid related stuff but every time I
bring this up to him he tries to flip it
around and say that he is so stressed
because he's expected to do everything
and carry all the weight it's been
recommended that we come up with a chart
that keeps track of who is supposed to
do what and what our roles are and we
started doing that recently but it
hasn't cut out all the fights completely
how do you handle this in your marriage
have you had similar problems well Kay
first part of my answer is that sure
yeah everybody has had issues like this
in their marriage everyone who's been
married for more than like three days
has had those kinds of arguments the
sort of you don't do anything and I do
everything types of arguments really
stupid arguments arguments that I just
are not productive and aren't gonna lead
anywhere but you know that's that's that
is normal so to have an argument like
that is normal but if you're having
those arguments all the time and you
can't get along at all and it's become
an obsessive focus and you've had to
resort to a chore chart then I think
there's a deeper issue here I think it's
a bigger problem as I'm sure you've
noticed so if I'm gonna be
straightforward with you Kay and and and
I'm gonna be blunt about it and you
gotta keep in mind I don't know
all I know is what you told me so I
don't know any the background but I
would say that it sounds like you guys
need to grow up a little I would say you
need to maybe mature because you're
adults but you're acting like feuding
siblings and so this intense obsessive
focus on everything being fair and
making sure that you're doing the exact
same amount of things and sharing the
burden exactly 50/50 is I think it's a
symptom of a symptom of immaturity more
than anything else which we're all
immature sometimes so that's not I don't
mean that has any kind of dramatic
condemnation but it is immature now I
don't know who recommended the chore
chart idea but I think that it's
honestly terrible and I think it's a
terrible way for married adults to
handle the distribution of duties in the
household and I'll tell you why I think
it's a terrible way that to handle the
distribution of duties in the household
it's because it completely removes - I
think essential agreed ingredients from
your marriage and those are gratitude
and generosity and those are ingredients
that it sounds like you guys are
desperately missing right now so a
solution that eliminates them is
probably not a great solution so if you
because if you have it written down
contractually that your husband is going
to do such-and-such take out the trash
do the dishes vacuum the living room on
Tuesdays and Thursdays or whatever
however you broke down the situation
whatever it is there there's no
generosity there's no love in him doing
it he's just doing it because it's his
thing on the chart and there's no reason
for you to be grateful that he did it
because it's what he's supposed to do
and it's on the chart and so he did it
and it seems to me that really and you
know I don't mean to try to read your
minds here but it seems like what you
both really want is gratitude
from the other and you want to feel like
the other one is being generous right
you want you want you want the other to
be grateful grateful for what you're
doing in the marriage and generous you
want them to be generous in giving
themselves putting in the work and the
effort and all that so I think any
solution that isn't focused on that is
gonna be a problem and I say this from
experience okay we've made the mistake
in the past in my marriage every every
couple has where you get too legalistic
about this sort of thing and you say you
do this and I do that let's keep it all
even and it doesn't work
what I think does work is for both
partners in the marriage to just keep
the other one in mind to stop thinking
so much about what you're doing and the
credit you deserve and what you need and
how much you need a break and all the
stress that you're under and so on and
so forth and instead to think about what
the other person needs and I think if
one spouse takes the lead on that and
leads by example not making a system out
of it and not making themselves into a
martyr but just gets up and does what
needs to be done I think the other one
will probably follow suit
I think the probably the goal is you
want to settle into natural roles where
you're both contributing in your own
unique way and where there's still the
opportunity for generosity and gratitude
and all that
one other thing so that's my that's my
answer there probably it wasn't it
probably wasn't much help but that's my
answer
I guess my my advice is just stop doing
you're having a problem my advice is
stop having that problem that would be a
very good therapist just stop okay
that's it give me $300 but one other
thing is that here's something maybe a
little bit more substantive or practical
anyway I do think it's extremely
important for for moms and dads I think
did you say you have kids you said there
was you made a reference to kids so you
have kids okay so I think it's extremely
important for moms and dads to both get
breaks on a regular basis not every six
months or something but on a regular
basis a break as in you get to leave the
house for a few hours and not to run an
errand or to go to work but you leave
the house on your own and you do your
own thing
you get a coffee you get a beer you work
out you watch a movie you go get a drink
with a friend whatever whatever you want
to do it doesn't matter but I think
that's really important sounds like you
both also feel like you need that and it
is important in a marriage and I hear
from both men and women all the time who
say that they haven't really had a
chance to get out and be by themselves
in years and there's just no excuse for
that if you're married there's no reason
why you can't on a regular basis get
those kinds of breathers there's two of
you after all right so you should be
able to go out and relax for a little
bit while your husband handles things at
home and vice-versa
you should both be able to do that so
while my wife and I have been far from
perfect and made plenty of mistakes this
is one area where I think we've always
been it's just we this is one area where
we're definitely on the same page I
think we've always been pretty pretty
good about it and giving each other
breaks now we don't keep a chart or
tabulate and it's not a quick
pro quo thing like you went out for 47
minutes and now I'm gonna know that's
not it's not like that it's just uh it's
just a general understanding that you
know sometimes my wife's got to get out
and have her own time I gotta get out
it's that's it I went I went recently to
watch a movie I'm by myself which I
enjoy doing
actually well I think a movie you don't
really need somebody there with you
right because it's no that's what you're
talking anyway so I went out recently a
watch a movie and and I was talking
about I mentioned it on online and all
these people were saying well how did
you wait you went to see a movie don't
you have four kids how did you do that I
haven't gone to see a movie in years
well why not why can't you if you have a
spouse right if you're a two-parent
household why can't if you want to go
see a movie go see a movie have your
spouse watch the kids I mean you
shouldn't be the only one doing that in
the marriage obviously but you should
both get a chance to do the stuff you
want to do is I just I just you know
this thing that people now I'm kind I
guess I'm I'm off on a different this
isn't exactly what you were asking about
but I do think it would be helpful to
you guys but you hear people talk about
having kids and being married and and
how they you know you give up your
personal life and you can't do the
things you want to do anymore
another one is fishing I talk about
sometimes I like to fish and I talked
about this that on this show sometimes
and I'll get emails from guys saying oh
you know I love fishing before I got
married and had kids but now that I now
that I got kids and I'm married I don't
have time for how I don't even they're
asking me how do you have time to fish
what what do you mean how do I have time
for it sometimes I want to go fishing I
tell my wife hey I want to go out on
Saturday afternoon and go fishing okay
why shouldn't I and she tells me hey I
want to go out with my friends might she
want to go down to DC recently and with
a friend to have have dinner and she was
good you know and okay go ahead so
that's I think that's got to be the the
attitude I think I think sometimes in
marriages both spouses can get so you
get into such a
module and you want to make sure that at
least it seems like this seems like it's
what you guys are going through where
every moment that you're working or
watching the kids or doing something
that's tedious or you know whatever it
is doing chores every moment that you're
doing that you want to make sure that
your spouse is also doing something like
that
or you feel put upon the idea of you
doing the hard stuff while your spouse
is out enjoying themselves for a little
bit for free I guess some people they're
getting in a marriage where they they
just can't handle that
but if that's your attitude it's
disastrous and it's not gonna work and
you're and you're just making it
miserable on both of you alright let's
see we have time for one more email
no probably not so we'll leave that for
tomorrow Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
again is the email address and I guess
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]